só hoje vou mostrar um truque de magia
exatos 12 usando cartas vai deixar toda
a gente de boca aberta e é outro que não
quer muita habilidade e confiança em dar
as cartas no baralho pronto aqui brincar
com as cartas são cartas normais o
legado que passa vou fazer o que mais
entrou que aprender os truques de mágica
dizem preparar para pronto você ter a
'carta mostra que você não vê a carta
mostra a pessoa volta a pessoa do outro
lado vai custar dez vezes mostrando vez
faltou esta carta não é você ouve custo
final na bomba em uma carta na mesa não
buscar dessa espetáculo e 3 não estava
ali no baralho e agora está aqui
é eu sei foi baralho volta e única carta
que vai faltar no baralho é esta e todas
as outras cartas não serem normais bem
só espero que tenham gostado e vai
juntar à inflação dá margem a fazerem
também lá em casa e até o próximo vídeo
só